a lot of my audience is gonna be going
to parties or trick-or-treating with
their kids now I want everyone to be
safe that's important so here with some
Halloween safety tips is our very own
Count Dracula let's get him in here good
evening boys and ghouls haha terror
rific to see you all I don't want to
sound like your mommy but before you
ghost trick-or-treating it's good to
exercise some caution there's a wrong
way and a right way to go I'm sorry
excuse me
Dracula do you think you just give the
safety advice without all the lame puns
I'm just trying to creep it real no no
I'm serious we're making really bad puns
and it's annoying alright it's been done
by hack TV vampires for at least 40
years can you just stop it no I can't
Dracula's right
he can't stop making horrible puns it's
a speech disorder common to vampires
but luckily there's a treatment at the
Lestat Institute for word therapy
researchers teach vampires to avoid puns
wordplay and double entendre using
cognitive behavioral techniques and
shock therapy the Lestat Institute for
word therapy dracula everyone wants to
know did they cure your puns and
wordplay yeah I guess they did yeah
apparently I'm a hundred percent cured
and by the way it's not Dracula now it's
just Daryl okay Daryl do you still have
some Halloween safety tips yeah not
really feeling that anymore you know
tomorrow I'll probably just stay home
and forget about Halloween maybe refocus
my efforts on Thanksgiving
[Music]
they didn't cure me that institute is
gold CID those techniques are horrible
no ifs ands or bats who's the sucker now
alright you're an idiot
you